la ciudad sagrada de kandy en el corazón
de sri lanka es la más concurrida en
esta época del año ya que la gente se
prepara para uno de los mayores
festivales del país el año nuevo
cingalés y también pero el aumento de
los precios en el país están frenando
los preparativos este año estos petardos
que solían ser los más vendidos no
tienen compradores las cosas son caras
en lugar de gastar su dinero en petardos
la gente prefiere gastarlo en arroz
azúcar y productos básicos los 20 80
céntimos cada uno la gente prefiere
comprar un kilo de arroz con ese dinero
en un momento en el que los srilanqueses
luchan por satisfacer sus necesidades
diarias es inimaginable planear algo
especial
o no es insoportable dios mío estoy
pagando casi el doble de precio en
comparación con el año pasado la aguda
escasez de combustible está provocando
cortes de electricidad de hasta 10 horas
y perjudicando al sector turístico que
es el que más divisas aporta al país los
propietarios de las casas de huéspedes
buscan constantemente cómo mantenerse a
flote
antes las utilizábamos como decoración
pero después de la crisis empezamos a
encender estas lámparas pero por
desgracia nos falta aceite
la falta de electricidad significa que
no hay aire acondicionado ni repelente
para mosquitos en mi refrigerador
hoy en día todos los alimentos son muy
caros los precios se han duplicado y el
despilfarro también el mundialmente
famoso tdt land también pende de un hilo
y ahora con las limitadas reservas de
divisas del país
las importaciones de fertilizantes se
ven interrumpidas
el precio era muy bajo el fertilizante
estaba subsidiado y estaba a cuatro
euros del saco de 50 kilos ahora la
información que nos llega de nuestros
proveedores es que está por encima de
los 40 euros mientras estas industrias
sufran es difícil que sri lanka salga de
la confusión económica